Minecraft means you love them. I love them. Let's watch them
Yeah, watch till the end of the video for a surprise now that I'm a Minecraft channel. I can finally understand
Minecraft memes so I asked you guys on Twitter
Send me your best minecraft memes. Let's see if we can make a scout that today. Welcome to
Minecraft edition
Ok, he's found diamonds. What is the twist a creeper don't dig down
Hey look nothing, uh
Stop stop
He's gonna jump in isn't he? Okay
That was a rollercoaster
They had us in the first half not gonna like I think they had me in every half
I never felt so literally trolled smash like if you got epically troll
That funny but at the same time it was the first time we saw creeper (aww man)
I mean a zombie in a minecart. It was funny. Damn Mike. I've looked different back. Then we call the Sun is everyone in there?
Get the fraps, this has to be documented no one's ever done this no
He's gonna die at it
These are always so good
This is my video game minecraft veteran, you know that you can jump off a high point in place of water
Right before you're only pros can do it. Take any fall damage. Ash such
Welcomed through the life of an idiot. I can laugh at my own jokes, cuz I don't remember them. The mental lag is brutal
That's the sad thing. I was actually trying
Can't wait for minecraft in 4k damn, Notch. Come on
You just make it happen since I play Minecraft now. I get this joke because it's not actually Minecraft. It's Spyro
Don't miss another minecraft set Lionel bring it to me
He had no loot are you kidding me? I don't believe that see I understand these joke now
It's the eye of Ensor. I get it. I get it. I'm part of you guys
I understand the joke so that funny but I get it see now
I can truly appreciate this cursed image now that I play Minecraft. Please kill it. Why do you think?
I don't like what are sheep. Let's get real here. Please stop it. I don't want to see your cursed imagery. Stop it
No, don't do that peepeepoopoo
Creeper
Awww man how did that even happen?
damn creepers of Notch(?) damn proud of himself for making tons of gamers suffer SM edge
I appreciate that minecraft air pods as well. I think this is more of a meme that I'm I can truly appreciate it
It's like wine. I don't go. Wow. This one tastes good. It's more like that's good.
I like that, I like this meme
Since Petey pyres now become a Minecraft youtuber I felt it was finally time to become a Minecraft editor
This is now a Minecraft page from now on smash like on that one. Thank you. Very cool
Just don't mind straight down no. Oh
My god, I guess trolls epically oh
Okay, that was good fine that was good brother lock is just great dude got my freshly enchanted diamond tools and
Um, my eyes are going black on the surface. Hey every time
Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba. Only true gamers can understand this moment. Only true gamers can understand
I understand like now that I play Minecraft. I understand the pain that this man is about to get inflicted upon himself
No
Don't you just go this way? Yeah, even the trees in the background
Oh
Force mad, it's not hey
That's alike. I like that one. That was good. What can I say? Sometimes you guys have good memes. All right, next one
peace out sucker
God I'm 77. He's not sucker
That's good, like half of the Minecraft memes is just falling or a creepers
Only true minecraft gamers can understand me hits Pigman by accident all Pigman in nether buenas Dias
This is like the only thing I haven't messed up yet in Minecraft. I'm pretty sure I just jinx myself. Yeah, I drinks myself
It's gonna happen
Normally, I'm like Oh Pigman, I should attack them minecraft big brain
I'm not gonna
Cool Felix good you want to tell us any more pointless information next game? Oh god, not Sven memes
I can't handle it
Okay
That's all
That guy I got this is sad little late. I feel that you laugh. You sad Hey Dolan got one
It's all items. You just have to take a risk
It's a good mean I have seen it already I'm sorry. Darlin come in the side dock son
But like before I got it but now I truly understand like I bet she thought she jumped into lava or something like crazy
Water Shh
The quality is so bad. I can't see what is that she closes it order very nice house
Water she I knew it. He's invading other people's world in dark souls
That's funny oh I see this skills around the corner
Don't go down
That's amazing 10 out of 10 smash like and subscribe I know we're in like it's clearly people reposing other people's content whatever
It's never stopped me before the Wi-Fi password is on the back of the router the back of the router
Yeah, why do they always make it so freakin encrypted? So that's the language of the enchantments. Okay. See I get it now
This is a minecraft mean I get it
I don't buy you guys
But I get it smash like of you and subscribe and buy the merch if you get it, I am wearing them out
It's just a little chilly today. Okay, just myth just to make sure
Just to make sure
kpop fans be like, oh my god, which was
Why does villagers exist and why did they give me nightmares?
I developed an AR app from your microwaves and put it on the Brighton Beach what the actual free curry? Oh
my god is the pier that
Was literally there yesterday. I didn't see it. What? Oh my god. They're entering
What can you guys imagine why is the Swedish flag not working that is weird
What their sheep gets the revenge of Kitty plank
Yeah, that's creepy, no, not the balance I got ya I
Can't believe everyone has my freaking world. No my Diamont what song is that? Oh
My god, it was this literally foreshadowing for after Jack Black. Does this mean Jack Black is water sheep. Stop it. So then do something
Worst guard dog. Oh listen, PC etiquette
Stop don't don't you dare touch IKEA tower. No
Delete this right now grande
What is this what flag is that?
No too far too far
Water ship is Norwegian. It all makes sense now. No, don't touch that
Brah brah
I'm shaking
Not y'all yet. He's already suffered it up
It even has my freaking contraption dude how
Not cool man not cool guys I fix Australia ding their boat I get it that huh
Thanks guys, I finally understand the me thank you very much. Thank you so much it took a while
But I finally got there only gamers know the real struggle and sacrifice
When you're suffering from success
That's a decent mean I gave a chuckle I'm still I still got my health bar though, I we're still doing that
No, it's minecraft. Ok, how do I how do I tame apparent? Hey look, it's me again
Right in front of me - come on how did he live through that? Oh my god
Oh my god
Ten out of ten editing. What's your name, beautiful?
He ate the cover so Marty McFly Williams F's in the chat for Marty McFly Williams boys, good night girl
I see you tomorrow
Good night girl, I see you tomorrow. I
Get it because you're not supposed to just go in the end reporter
I get it 90% bug free 10% of bugs good mean I get it if I didn't play my crime
Probably would not understand
Why is this a thing I'm very confused but it also makes me laugh and I don't know why
Hey, look, it's the immersive Asian maybe edition question mark in the future
Of course Grande this video is not for the faint-hearted. Well, the last one was painful enough. Okay, let's watch it
Stop stop Oh
God
Hey at least ha ha ha
Ok sure
What else could he possibly do to annoy me
Is that obsidian yeah. Okay great. I
Feel like the team starts screaming meme saw that Tilly hates
Now I truly know what keeps our we're screaming about but playing my track oh
My gosh, you can't melt obsidian crinch what
Now get biscuit nugget in a biscuit Hey, look what I didn't know that worked
What can you possibly do with redstone of course
How's that even possible that made no sense guys
See, I played Minecraft and I can I can honestly tell you guys this makes no sense
You can't just summon the withered he's from call of duty black ops. Everyone knows that stop using my world. How did this happen?
Get out
Gosh damn it. Don't touch the vein. Don't touch don't you dare? Okay. Good good
Damn it. My mom my dad see there it is. There's a screaming team sir
He lives in all of us
See everyone loves minecraft it brings people together. It makes you have a good time and not worry about all that petty BS
Look at that if they can get a long before cap
Minecraft then we all can thank you so much for watching this episode smash like subscribe by the merch which I am wearing
And I see you guys next time
What you never played super simulator
You know, it's fun right I'm not supposed to give my opinion
But give it a try and then you can tell me if it's good or not not convinced yet. Okay. I'll cut you a deal
The game is available for free and that's a great price